foreign
[Music]
this morning Jay's Artisan Pizza the
unlikely story of two guys from Western
New York shooting up the rankings of
best pizza in the world we noticed the
top 50 Pizza list this year and Industry
standard most of the pizzerias were in
Naples and Rome a few in New York City
in Paris then there's one in Buffalo
Kenmore New York to be specific
how did that happen to find out you have
to speak with Jay and Joe
Powers is a 24 year old Pizza Prodigy he
studied first under restaurateur Jay
langfelder before rounding out his
training in Naples
this year on the world's most respected
Pizza ranking list curated by three
Italians the shop J started and Joe now
runs came in at 71st best pizza in the
world and 13th in the United States
Joe was always asking questions he
wanted to know what you were doing you
know it wasn't just make the pizza he
wanted to know why he wanted to know why
we did things a certain way and that
made you believe that he could do this
by himself I know he already was it was
it was fun and like it's it's been a
really good experience like learning how
to like I guess be myself you know
Joe and Jay's rapid rise to Global Pizza
superstardom gave us a chance to do an
Americanized dish dive into the world of
traditional Neapolitan style for the
uninitiated the difference between
neapolitan pizza and the pizza you
normally would have delivered to your
house so a neapolitan pizza is cooked
extremely hot and extremely fast so it's
going to be much softer and kind of a
puffy Corner tone and it's going to be a
lot fresher of a pizza than something
you get in a box that was big for eight
or ten minutes so ideally these are
eaten within minutes of coming out of
the oven
pizza meant to be eaten hastily is best
prepared exactingly so I'm just going to
dump that in there
we're just gonna put uh 10 grams of
yeast in yeah and you're gonna kind of
like rub it in between your hands so
we're just gonna go like that and it's
just gonna fall right into the water
so then we're going to weigh out all the
flour
this is a Caputo double zero flower
what's double zero double zero is just
like the type of flower that it is if
you're going by like neapolitan pizza
like traditions double zero flour
start it we'll come back in seven
minutes and see what it looks like okay
once the mixture was complete Joe formed
the dough into 12 perfectly smooth round
balls before introducing us to another
time-honored tradition
this is the Neapolitan slap yes yeah all
the pizza on Naples
so that looks about good then we're
gonna
bring it right there about a 12 inch
disc next my turn so now you're going to
get your your hand like this yeah three
fingers underneath and you're like
throwing it and then you're also
rotating it curl and rotate yep
so throw it over yeah rotate it yeah
hey if it was easy everybody would do it
right that's close whoops yeah
now it was time to give our pie a little
taste of the old country
so we're gonna do one scoop of the
tomatoes that we get from
um Italy then we're gonna go with a
little Parmigiano-Reggiano gives it a
little bit of saltiness a little bit of
bite
this is some basil that we get from
somebody locally who grows it
hydroponically it's it's really really
great basil and then we have a little
bit of fresh mozzarella
I'm just gonna spread out oh yeah spin
it out like that do you want me to put
it on the peel and you launch it in the
oven no I'm doing the whole thing doing
the whole thing yeah all right you're
gonna SL you're gonna go one quick
motion slide right underneath you're
going to lower lower your backhand keep
this flush to the table and you're gonna
go straight through it
foreign
if at first you don't succeed
ask a pro
oh you did it perfectly yeah okay all
that was left was to launch it into the
oven find your spot put it on it and
then one quick motion out yep angle it
down and pull it there you go like a
samurai yeah and only about 60 seconds
later our neapolitan pizza was ready to
eat
foreign
[Music]
the classic margarita was served along
with an induya pizza with chili honey
and basil
fungi with confi garlic and truffle
pecorino the Zooka with butternut squash
puree maple syrup and pumpkin seeds
and a pesto Neapolitan with roasted
tomatoes Joe also threw in a Detroit
style with cherry peppers
for desserts
panna cotta what is it about neapolitan
pizza that you thought would work so
well
you know I had worked in Buffalo
pizzerias for forever and I love buffalo
style pizza as much as the next guy but
I just felt like this area was missing
all these other varieties of pizza that
you can find across the world and in the
U.S I mean it seems crazy to say that as
the goal is the goal eventually to have
the number one pizza it's a goal but I I
don't know it's not the number one goal
wow like it isn't it when Joe called me
to tell uh tell me that they were 13 in
the U.S though I think the first thing
that came to both of our minds is how do
we get in the top five
I want to know what the top five are
there well it's a lot it's a lot of Rome
Naples it's all it's European pizzas
there's some in New York City but this
is why it was yeah I just thought it was
so interesting and I don't have it here
because as we explained in the piece you
have to make it yeah right away I owe
you a neapolitan pizza you do Jeff they
look delicious